this was the moment a Russian military
transport plane crashed to the ground
prompting conflicting claims and counter
claims about what and who was on
board Russian officials say the uan 76
similar to this one was transporting 65
Ukrainian prisoners of War for a
prisoner
exchange they claim anti-aircraft
missiles were detected being launched
from the Ukrainian side of the Border
on the morning of January 24 Moscow time
a terrorist Act was committed as a
result of which in the area of the
belgorod region a Russian Transport
Aircraft was shot down which was
carrying out a flight to transport 65
military personnel of the Armed Forces
of Ukraine from the Moscow region to
belgrad who were accompanied by three
Russian officers and a crew of six
people they all died the claims were
immediately treated with deep suspicion
by Ukraine that accuses Russia of
conducting longstanding disinformation
campaigns it is obvious that the
Russians are playing with the lives of
Ukrainian prisoners with the feelings of
their relatives and with the emotions of
our society it is necessary to establish
all clear facts as much as possible
given that the plane crash happened on
Russian territory beyond our control
facts is the key word
now
officially Ukraine says it has no
evidence of its prisoners of War being
on the plane but a statement by military
intelligence has hinted that if they
were on board Russia was responsible for
their safety blaming Moscow for not
informing keev of Transport arrangements
for the prisoner swap and for flying PWS
so close to an active war zone
establishing the truth has been made
Harder by the secrecy that surrounds the
highly sensitive exchanges of Russian
and Ukrainian prisoners this was the
last prisoner swap carried out at New
Year even Russia's list of the Ukrainian
PS they say were on the plane is being
disputed with a number of social media
posts questioning the veracity of some
of the names Rob McBride Al jaaz
Keith make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer